Jay and Silent Bob are coming back to spoof
comic book movies, Hollywood, and more once
again in Jay and Silent Bob Reboot.
But what if Jason Mewes' and Kevin Smith's
iconic stoner duo did more than just smoke
herb and spoof superheroes?
What if they actually went out and joined
the superheroes' world?
It's not as strange as it might sound.
Kevin Smith has directed and appeared on episodes
of the CW's Arrowverse franchise, and Mewes
has made appearances on the shows as well.
The duo have also long lent their likenesses
to the Red Bank, New Jersey comic book store
Jay and Silent Bob's Secret Stash, owned by
Smith since the late '90s.
You may recognize it as the setting of AMC's
Comic Book Men, also developed and produced
by Smith.
Long before the Arrowverse or the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, Smith's own View Askewniverse beat
Marvel Studios to the shared universe concept
by an entire decade, with Jay and Silent Bob
being the main thread tying together many
different movies.
Smith's films have even had comic book tie-ins,
and Jay and Silent Bob have in-universe comic
book alter egos: Bluntman and Chronic, both
of whom are making a return in the story of
Jay and Silent Bob Reboot.
So, Jay and Silent Bob have comic book bona
fides, that's been long established.
But what would it look like if Bluntman and
Chronic joined a slightly more serious superhero
universe?
What if they suddenly jumped from the Askewniverse
to something a little more fantastical?
We spoke with Jason Mewes about that possibility
during promotion for his new movie and directorial
debut, Madness in the Method.
During our chat, we got to talking about the
sweeping next phase of the MCU, which will
include the animated Disney+ series What If…?,
a take on the classic series of speculative
Marvel comic books.
Considering that Marvel Comics has in the
past crossed over with the likes of Star Trek,
Transformers, and Ash from Evil Dead, it's
not such a weird thing to wonder: what if
Jay and Silent Bob went out and joined the
MCU?
If anyone knows the answer, it's Jason Mewes,
a lifelong comic book fan.
And while he may be sober these days, he knows
his on-screen stoner character inside and
out.
"I feel like Jay and Bob would be, like, Bruce
Wayne and Dick Grayson of Earth-14, and then
we'd turn into Bluntman and Chronic.
So it could almost be like a What If…?"
Mewes imagined the characters' origin story
as being something straight out of Batman
Begins, which is DC-branded, sure, but we
don't think anyone's going to sue.
"Instead of finding the Batcave, and the bats
give Bruce Wayne the idea to dress as a scary
bat...Jay and Bob going into a cave, and a
bunch of weed is in there.
And then all of a sudden we're like, 'There's
the idea, we'll scare everyone with our Chronic
and Bluntman.'"
In other words, move over, Moon Knight.
This dynamic duo would make for a much more
amusing take on Batman-style crime-fighting.
Maybe they can cross over at the same time
as Deadpool.
"Yeah it's me, Deadpool, and I've got an offer
that you can't refuse!"
Of course, there's more than one way to join
the MCU.
Technically speaking, Mewes already exists
in the Marvel movie world, as do Jay and Silent
Bob.
That's all thanks to the late Stan Lee, who
made one of his last on-screen appearances
in 2019's Captain Marvel.
Set in the 1990s, the movie shows Lee reading
the script for Kevin Smith's Mallrats while
sitting on a train, memorizing his lines out
loud to himself.
Lee also previously made a cameo appearance
in that movie, Smith's second, featured in
the cast alongside Jay and Silent Bob.
"They look happy, don't they?"
"What, the bras?"
But enough of this in-universe speculation,
let's just get direct about it.
Jason Mewes is a working actor, so are there
any comic book characters out there he'd want
to play?
The answer is, well, yes, not that he would
necessarily accept the offer to play them.
"I think Vigilante or Deadshot would be really
cool to play, 'cause they're two of my favorite
DC characters.
But I don't think I'd want to play a character,
because I love watching the movies, the TV
shows so much."
Mewes appears to feel this way in general,
not seeming to want to join in on the things
he enjoys experiencing as a fan.
"I feel like it would throw me out of the
universe if I'm sitting and watching, you
know, Netflix's Daredevil, and I was playing,
you know, one of the main characters.
Even if it was Froggy Nelson."
He probably means "Foggy Nelson," but give
the guy some credit: "Froggy Nelson" is a
real character, so long as you're reading
about Deerdevil, and not Daredevil.
"I just feel like I wouldn't be able to sit
and enjoy watching it and really getting into
the stuff if I was a main, main character.
But of course I'd love to be in any of the
movies, TV shows, if I was like 'Journalist
#2' who, you know, got to interview them one
or two scenes out of the series, or once in
the movie or something."
He doesn't just talk the talk on this topic,
either.
This is more or less exactly what he's done
on the Arrowverse series The Flash, on which
he's played two characters: "Humvee Guy" and
"Jay the Security Guard."
"That's my mom's car!"
So, while you might not see Mewes headlining
a superhero show on DC Universe or Disney+,
you can definitely catch him making hay on
his home turf as Jay and his alter ego: the
OG Chronic.
You can see Jay and Silent Bob team up again
in Jay and Silent Bob Reboot's touring roadshow,
kicking off on October 15.
And you can also check out Mewes' reunion
with Stan Lee in Madness in the Method.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.